I certainly hope you dance as well as
you
dress there's only one way to find
out you and I we're not so different
agent
arile it'll help hold
[Music]
on
M the book is phenomenal sweetie
but what happens next it's called a
cliffhanger mother Ellie it's called a
copout whoa hey there's a cat in
there oh my God you're Ellie freaking
Conway author of ARG series ell
Conway I am such a fan oh yeah what does
it you do Espionage would you sign my
book here we
go I love this
book come
[Music]
on who are these people real life spies
why would they care about me because
you're a goddamn fortune teller
Ellie when you wrote in your new book
actually happened and you kicked the
Hornet's Nest you didn't even know
existed I'm in some really big trouble
Mom oh so now you're experimenting with
drugs I want all assets on them now I
need her to write the next
chapter God I hate that cat
we
can't
together
[Music]
suici it's time for you to meet the real
agent
Argy oh my God oh my God oh my
God
amen